all right anaya and i uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
i'm from centennial hospital cincinnati
hospital
so what what city did you grow up um la
los angeles englewood um yes so let's
let me let me start over and just say
inglewood because otherwise
yeah eaglewood um la to be exact um
englewood is in l.a so yeah let me start
off
and just say inglewood when i asked you
where yeah i'm from um
right here i'll ask you first um i mean
i was born in inglewood but
like i've never grew up in this
neighborhood
like where'd you grow up well me and my
mom we
moved to victorville when i was like 10.
because of the violence like our house
got shot up when i was a kid oh yeah so
it is
victorville yeah so victorville is safer
yeah
and how was your childhood
my childhood was uh i've seen a lot of
things that i shouldn't
that i wasn't supposed to see like um
you know my mom bringing in dudes in the
house and
you know um
you know just her getting drunk and
everything like that um
you know my mom she's an alcoholic so
she just always used to like bring
dudes in and um
i tried to go to sleep when i was a kid
but she'd always have like music playing
and blasting
and um i tried to go to sleep but
i couldn't sleep because i knew my mom
was doing something wrong
that she wasn't supposed to be doing and
i just wanted to be with my dad because
my dad
always was there for me and um
my dad is not a deadbeat he's always
he's he's a good
my dad is good and um
my dad loves me so much and
my dad loves me more than my mom and
that's why i live with my dad
half of my life but my uh
me and my mom we fought i fought my mom
and
you know i know that's a sin but i
fought my mom
um like we acted like i actually
socked her in her face and all that but
um
me and my mom we don't get along because
she's an alcoholic and she's jealous
of me her own daughter so
you know do you have siblings yeah i
have six i have
six brothers and two sisters we all have
different dads
same mom and your dad was
kind of in your life or not my dad was
always in my life he was yeah he's
always there for me
he's always there so there were drugs in
the house as well or just alcohol no not
in my dad's house just alcohol
my dad yeah but your mom's no she's just
alcohol um
she um
she hook up with the other guys and they
get her high up pills and
ecstasy and all that um
she'd be so drunk like she has one
boyfriend that's
one guy that's there for her that it's
always helping her out
she gets so drunk to the point where she
fall out and
i see that you know i seen it
and
it's not nice to see being her kid you
know
um
who wants to see their mom like you know
drunk and
falling over drunk like you know
so drunk to the point where she hits her
head and
i don't know she's just an alcoholic so
i try to be there for her she says that
she loves me and
i try to be there with her but
my mom is crazy so
that's why she tries to keep my daughter
from me
because i'm not in my right state of
mind
but
i want to change the subject so what
kind of kid were you in high school
what kind of what what kind of kid were
you in high school um
i was a good kid i didn't understand
math
i always felt math like i tried to go up
to the board and like
because the teacher called on me to
solve a problem
and i try to go up to the board and
well in the suburbs when i went to uh
rsm intermediate high school
intermediate middle school and
they called me up to the board and
i was embarrassed because i couldn't
solve a problem
that uh
algebra problem i couldn't solve that i
couldn't solve the problem and
i felt singled out because it was all
white people
you know and
one kid walked up
after me before i left the
the white board i went back to my seat
and he walked up
he solved the problem and everybody
laughed
and that's something that i won't forget
i still don't i still don't understand
it you know
i'm good in history you know i can do
this through
so you left helmet what age um
16 16 did you finish high school um i
dropped off
i dropped out when i was in 11th grade
and where'd you go um to the streets
um i was 16 when i got this tattoo here
my first tattoo beauty spain
and then um i dropped out
because
i think my mom lost her house so i i was
living with my mom at the time and she
lost the house so
um i dropped out
and um
i don't have a high school diploma but i
i went to i was in orange county and i
i went to uh this and uh
continuation school called access
in orange county and
my credits were building up but i
dropped out of that too
um
i almost made it but i mean i think i
can still go to adult school but
you know um i don't have a diploma or
anything but
i can still try to go and
you know make something out of myself
how old are you
23. 23. yeah so where do you live now
i'm homeless currently i'm home i'm
currently i'm homeless right now
living on skid row uh skid row
no um you know
you just come you you came down here
today for
something but you're you live where
all my life i live like when you're
homeless where do you stay at night
um i sleep wherever like you know i
sleep in cars i sleep
i sleep in cars i sleep in motels i
sleep in
the bus stop i sleep
wherever you know wherever yeah you're
swinging
are you using any of the drugs that are
on the street um
well i've been doing meth for about i'll
say now for about six years
um i've never shot it but i smoke it and
i started off i started i first started
using i started uh
snorting it then i started smoking it
i never shot it but i've done the hot
rail but
i don't really want to do a hot roll
anymore because that gives me way out of
my mind
you know it takes me somewhere where i
don't want to be
how do you support yourself now um
i don't
but to buy food or clothes or
um or meth or whatever costs money
people help me out
you know because i'm just like everybody
else because i'm homeless now
so i'm just like everybody else you know
so
i might get blessed for like a few
dollars or you know water bottle or
you know food or you know a cigarette
whatever it is
so a lot of the girls on the street are
dating guys for money you don't do that
i've yeah i've done it but
i've done it but like when i was 16 when
i left my mom's house
and i want my friend beauty i tried i
ran behind her i wasn't being a leader i
was being a follower
so i thought i wanted to follow her
and lead and you know do what she did
but that wasn't really my motto
that was just something that
i was trying to do to
i guess fit in and be you know grown at
the time
but i wasn't you know just
just you know i was just a little girl
just moving too fast you know
and you have a child yeah she's uh two
uh her name is abella uh abella eileen
sanders
and she's with your mom she's with my
mom yeah
how often do you see her i see her i
don't see her
i was supposed to see her um
on my birthday but never called my mom
i was too stuck up in my own ways you
know because of my
it was my birthday so i was just
thinking about myself you know
at the time
what do you think about your life may
have
led you down this path
was it your realization your
relationship with your mom
i think that is what it is it's also
that and
you know when my grandma passed away she
told me that i was gonna get what i
deserve
for disrespecting her and she did
everything
just to make me happy when i was little
she did everything she could
she bought me clothes mcdonald's all the
time
you know she um she was there for me all
the time
picked me up from school all the time
when my dad did it she was always there
for me
she was always there for me
but i disrespected her when i was uh
i disrespected her when i was when i was
younger
so this this life living on the street
no responsibility
no bills no no nothing is is
something you enjoy do you think or no i
don't like it
no i want bills i mean no i don't want
bills but
i want you know i want an apartment and
everything like that you know i want
somewhere to stay
you know um i don't want to be homeless
like it's not for me
what do you think stops you from getting
your life together
honestly me if i don't try hard enough
when i'm putting the credit to the
effort to
try to survive and thrive like stronger
and
just be like independent and just do
everything that i have to do
like it's not really hard i just have to
try
but i mean i can do it on my own but
then again it's like
everybody needs help you know
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your 23 years
um treat people how you want to be
treated
do you have friends i don't i don't
really
consider people
my friends who i just meet come up to me
asking me for favors
you know they're not really my friends
there's just
people in need you know where are your
siblings
i actually i don't know they're um you
know my uh
they all they we they moved out of my
mom's house
we are we're all grown up now like you
know my brother's in colton
my
my uh youngest brothers in colton
my other brothers in victorville um
my other brother stays out here in l.a
my other brother stays in orange county
and then
my other brother is adopted i don't know
where he is but
you know
you know that's what it is you can't
change anything that's
meant to stay the same
do you feel like you get in your own way
sometimes
and you put yourself in this situation
or do you
blame your your childhood with your mom
or something like that i blame it on my
mom
my grandma was my real mom if you
honestly um
you know my mom she you know what i do
love my mom but it's like
i have regrets because of what
she's had what she's done all the things
that i've seen
in the way that she treated me like she
called me hoes and [ __ ] and all that
like when i was like
like 10 years old
like 10 up like up in
10 up until like 16 to
23. like it she just won't change
like you know i don't know what i can do
to make her happy but
you know consider homegirls ever since
she started hanging out with this
her homegirl because her homegirl
called her homegirl calls her kids
[ __ ]
and so ever since she started hanging
around her
she started you know
picking up her sling and all that so
do you think that affects the way you
maybe subconsciously believe you what
you deserve
in life like maybe you don't deserve a
better life if you're if your own mother
is oh yeah i do deserve a better life
but it's like
i'm just so stuck in the i think it's
because of my age
i think that's what it is i'm not ready
to let go yet
but i think like once i get older a
little bit or once i get my [ __ ]
together i'll
you know i'll let go of it i'll let it
go
but right now it's just like
it hurts really bad
what's the most frustrating thing you
deal with the most fresh frustrating
thing is
um see i'm grown now
and it's like because when i was younger
like when i was 18
to like 10 to 18 to 17
i was my mom and dad now it's like
because i'm older
i don't they're not there anymore
you know and that's the most frustrating
thing
what about your child
that's frustrating too cause i'm not
there for her either
and where do you see yourself your life
going from here you're still young so
you have a lot of time there
um honestly i see myself
i know that i'm gonna make it
i know what i'm gonna make
if i try hard enough i know that i'll
make it
but it's not that easy you know
there's always something in the way you
know
you can't trust anything
i can't trust myself
as long as i love myself and love god
and
try to be better than i was yesterday
and i can do it
that's all i have to say
you